you you asked
how i maintained being a somewhat normal
real person and it literally goes back
to me being
a child uh growing up in a mortuary and
you asked
what are the benefits of that it was
very beneficial it opened up my eyes
if if let's say everybody at the age of
18 has to experience
death so they can appreciate their life
i think that's a great thing but i
was experienced at a very young age i
didn't and it
was very impactful to my whole existence
and i just think
that that we we don't have a lot of time
on on earth
like we don't like 80 years is in a long
time 100 years
no there's never and you don't know when
it's going to end but i can tell you
that's
in my experience when i've died and i
survived something where
dmt was released in my brain and i
experienced death but survived and
the life flashed everything and then at
the end i
i was able to let go surely dying
of my life on this planet because of
being at peace with my decisions and the
things i've done and who i am
and that is i think the most powerful
thing and the most important thing
that we all need to think about and
really
consider because it can come like that
how did you almost do
your heart stopped no uh i went
skydiving
and oh dude i went skydiving for the
first time and only time and they
partnered me up with this dude
named stevo i'm not even kidding and
and he was dread dreaded kid like in his
20s and
i went skydiving tandem and the
parachute didn't open
correctly and so we went to this g4
spiral and then he cut the parachute
and then i i was falling and that was it
as far as i was concerned and i had no
control over
that dmt releasing in my brain it just
did it totally did and i was
that was it i we were free-falling to
death and he was screaming
too and i'm like and it popped
and you know that is one time and i've
had it another time
not as severe and i've realized these
things
it's it's just really need to like
you know that's crazy yeah the
thoughtful of the existence
there's a talk given by alan watts where
he was like one of the best things you
can do in life
is contemplate death for a long time
because it's a similar
thing where you it's like pouring manure
all over your brain
because then flowers start to spring
from it and i always kind of
really like that yeah that is good i
mean it's a western society thing man
people just don't want to [ __ ] think
about it they don't want to think it's
much better to think about it so that
you can have lived your life
deliberately
exactly exactly sure like you didn't
just let things happen to you you you
were
good let's go party dude let's go party
yeah dude i love you man thanks for
doing this man
thanks for having me it's called stevo's
hot sauce for your butthole
and if you go on amazon and type in
stevo's hot sauce for your butthole
and order yourself a bottle you'd be
really helping me
because right now we're ranked number 30
on all of amazon
and if you buy a bottle we might go up
the ladder
and that would mean a lot so please get
on amazon
and buy stevo's hot sauce for your
butthole
yeah yeah
dude